all right Donald yes sir Donald uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally Warren Ohio
tell me about your family I came we came
from Cleveland we got my father
on uh what you call at that time
he was on the chitlin run
and the chitlin run consisted of all the
black entertainers who could not go into
Arena so they went into clubs
and during that time it was a very
successful business in Cleveland
my own
Black Mafia they tried to buy it for my
father and he refused so
they kidnapped my oldest Brothers
and my mother
and three of her children jumped into a
station wagon with everything that they
could put into that station where and
tied to the top of it
and my father said Center to California
he said he was going to stay in
Cleveland and bring his boys home
and in the process of bringing boys home
it took him
four to five days he arrived in
California Compton California with his
two sons and in the process he had to
surrender his business
in Cleveland
in order to freeze boys
and that was necessary
how would you describe your childhood in
general I had a very good childhood
private schools
spoiled
everything
that a child could want good family
my father was the first black man black
person in California to own a Mobil gas
it got robbed
and my mother forced them to sell it
because all she could Envision was her
children one of her children getting
killed in the process of a robbery
so he sold it and but I must say
I had everything I didn't know what poor
was
I didn't know what Rich was
all I knew was we were where we're at I
thought everyone owned the house I
thought everyone had a car and I thought
everyone
had a refrigerator full of food
anything outside of that was
unimaginable for me
but then
my father died
when I was eight
he died unexpectedly
because he did not like doctors
and when he did go to the doctor
he was in
a stage of cancer
that he could not return
so
he died and um this is why I lost all
faith in God Jesus all that
is when
he died I did exactly
what the private school taught me
to pray
that that Jesus brought back
the dead allowed to allowed the deaf to
hear and allow the blind to see that's
all I knew and that's all I was taught
so at that time
I did exactly what they asked me to do I
prayed diligently I built the little
thing in my backyard and I prayed every
day for my daddy to come back
and I had no clue
or no I thought there was no way
that God would not give me my daddy back
I didn't do anything wrong I wasn't a
bad kid I never stole nothing I never
killed nobody so why would God not give
me what I asked for in a sincere desire
I pray and I recall going whereas we
were at the funeral and when we were at
the graveyard I was waiting for that
moment for that coughing to open up and
he said I'm back
and the family could be back together
that never happened I remember peering
over the top the hole in the ground
waiting patiently for him to say I'm
back
he didn't do it
and at that moment I said [__] Jesus he
didn't work for me
and a few weeks later my mother was so
distraught from from having to raise six
children by herself
that a woman on the street she said
there's a pastor you need to go to this
church
he's a wonderful Pastor my mother said
okay and my sister and I went and in the
process I never seen nothing like this
this man wore sunglasses he wore a black
leather coat and he sweated
like he couldn't stop sweating and the
whole time he was yelling in the name of
Jesus and I heard this echo my mind few
weeks later that man took took that
family that introduced us to that church
to Ghana and they drank that Kool-Aid
that man was Jim Jones
and what I left what that left me with
is I don't want no part of Jesus
if he's taking my friends and my family
and having them die if he's not allowing
my father to come back to life [__] him
and that's how I believe
and um it was very difficult for me
because I could not
tell nobody
that I did not believe in Jesus and I
definitely didn't have no [__] faith
in it
so I couldn't tell nobody how I felt but
if you ever said a prayer around me I
would say
if you say in the name of Jesus I would
say you [__] the prayer up and I meant
that to the core of my heart and I and I
carried that
for 40 years
unable to depend or reach on any type of
spirituality to ground me but I couldn't
tell no one because I was too
embarrassed to let them know that I
didn't believe Jesus worked for me
because that was the only entity I have
ever heard in a spiritual life
I believe there was a God I just didn't
believe Jesus
and I carried that in my heart for a
long time
and um
I've been to 21 program
in the most difficult
phase
was when they would tell me
I had to turn my life
over to a power
created me
I couldn't do that
I could not
grass
what are you
see
an idea
on a Thing Called Jesus
to help me to my attention
so I could never do that phase of the
program
skipped it I lied about it
[Music]
I've been heavily hostage
long time
when did you discover correct
my best friend choose crack to me
when I came home from college
I never I never would have perceived in
my greatest
had a friend
I trusted tears
to introduce me to something
that would affect my life
the last 32 years
because this person who introduced me to
it
if he would told me John was okay to
jump off this bridge you gonna live I
would jump off that bridge
because I trust him
and um
so I didn't know what sprung was
I didn't know
what addictive was
I didn't know any of that I was
extremely naive
I came home from college after being
kicked out
my sister
is that USC
she's third in the nation in scoring
I'm embarrassed
that my mother
is idolizing following each and every
step my sister make you know
I'm embarrassed that I got kicked out of
college
after working so hard to get there
so I came home and I asked the only
thing I knew was to talk to my friend
because I didn't know
I didn't know how to talk to anyone else
about it about what do I do now
because they thought I was going back
they thought I was just home for summer
but I was kicked out
and I went to my friend and I just
wanted to talk
I just needed to sit down
and air out what was going on
he said
let's do it like we used to last
we we would we would smoke a Primo about
once every
three months and we would play
basketball all day it never affected
they never had no adversity in my life
then we would have a beer for alcohol
straight away
it was like one time ago so I go back to
my friend and I said come on man let's
go get a beer let's have a primo and
kind of kid he said man we don't do that
no more I said you don't do that they
don't do that and what you mean
he said we play baseball now what's that
we free based cocaine
what is that
how much does it cost
he said you got to give me sixty dollars
to be able to
okay because I had a lot of money at
that time I gave it to him
King William purses
yeah it was his brother him and myself I
didn't know his brother and my friend
were addicted they were Robins feeling
doing whatever is necessary to give
I love it so
they did what every day I'm sitting
there watching them go through this
ritual with this pipe and all that
and again and I watch as I'm watching
them take a hit
something in my heart and mind said
something about that ain't right
but I wanted to be okay with my best
friend
he gave me one
and it has Zero Effect
the next day I still needed to talk
about my issue about not being able to
go back and I go back to him again
and he said do it again that's okay
but he did something
to that pot the second time
which I never experienced before and
what it did was
I no longer felt the pain
of being kicked out of college
of feeling less than
I no longer felt the insecurities
that I carried Within Me
once I
he gave I don't know what he did to that
pipe
but it rang some bell in me and that was
the first time I was numb to reality and
I didn't feel absolutely nothing
and then it became
a two to three times a week process
and I'm paying for all the episodes
I just didn't know
you've had jobs in your life I had two
jobs in my feet I had two jobs in my
whole life
what'd you do I was administrative aide
for United Way
man they like me so much they asked me
they wrote a proposal
for me to get my own program in 23
if they accept
um
they accept the proposal willing to fund
it
doing my other job I had was a security
guard a fat Cole when I was 16.
but from
26 to now
I've been basically self-employed
I started selling T-shirts in concerts
but that revolved to
during concert's football game back okay
every event that you see in California I
have a hand on
I Supply T-shirts from Seattle all the
way to Houston
it's very very very very very very
profitable
and that's how I've been taking care of
myself that's how I've been able to go
you've been married yes I've been
married 22 years
I lost my wife
due to my addiction
I lost my kids
I lost my grandchildren
because I decided to come out here and
not go back home
and when I come see I don't I don't do
anything else during the course of the
year I'm a workaholic
but may around the 12th to the 16th
month of me being clean I get the bright
idea that I just wanna
also relax
and I just want to take one hit
and go home
I haven't been able to pull that off for
the last 19 years
every time I come and take one it turns
into a month it turns into two months it
turns into prison terms
turns into cards being repossessed with
me losing cars and mostly me going to
jail
good idea what was ever necessary
for me to continue
to feel what I feel which was absolutely
nothing and when I took that hit I no
longer felt the shame on me hurting my
family I no longer felt the guilt I mean
leaving my family [__] okay I no longer
felt
the shame because I come into Skid Row
together
because I cannot get high anywhere else
I can't get high in my city because
because of the businesses out
so I come into this place to hide
because any and everybody that I know
has no reason to be in security
so I can come here and do it and not be
judged
and not be ostracized because of what I
do
I've been a 21 problems
and I need to say
I didn't go to the program for me
I went through them programs
to get back get the grace of my mama
back to get the grace of my wife back to
get the grace of my brothers back to get
this trust that I may try one more time
but I never really wanted to stop
smoking okay I just didn't want to do it
every day
but yeah my mind share okay I can do it
once in a while
when I go to Bahamas sitting on the
beach or Jamaica
all the Virgin Islands or taking one of
them cruise ship rides that my wife and
I take three times a year
and that has always been one of my deep
dark secrets
I never wanted to tell anyone
that
I I don't want to completely stop but my
mama want me to come to my wife with me
where do you live now
that was my mother
I lost my wife and my family to the
divorce
so I moved back home
my mother been in that house City for a
year
she's 96 years old
I'm the one who's supposed to be
watching off
but sorry you say I took a hit three
weeks ago and haven't been back home
you've been down here for three weeks
three weeks
do you have employees I will not my
employees are coming down here and said
Donald please man come back to work man
give us a schedule man we got families
to take care of and all that man
the cocaine dominates me in such a way
it was none of that matter
my mind only shared when I'm done I'm
done but I'm coming to find out I may
never be done
this [__] will will take me either To My
Grave or give me a lifetime Independence
because I don't have the ability to turn
it off
I don't have the ability to say I don't
want no more I don't have the ability
to do to make a right decision when it
comes to crack cocaine
it dominates me in such a way which I
abandoned my family
I abandoned my mother right now my
brothers and them I have to stay at the
house and watch over
I suppose I spoke to my mother
and she said um
you won't be okay Tyler um
I just want to hug you
that haunts me up
because I know at any moment something
could happen to my mother
and I would definitely blame myself
because I allow myself to be put in a
position
here
to not go
let me bust it up
not getting my car and drive home
go
and I'm getting real close
but it's real close I understand you're
addicted to crack I get that but what is
it that keeps you
running around these streets instead of
being where you should be phenomenal I
believe that now
the book says the phenomenal Crane and
the phenomically it's something that
will not allow me to stop I understand
there's a phenomenal craving but is
there something about yourself
your subconscious self image yourself I
don't want to feel nothing
that that's what I think might be
I Stay Loaded all day every day
I don't want to feel the pain I don't
want to think about the hurt
that I've inflicted on people
I don't want to face the reality and I'm
a skid row
I don't want to face reality I'm in
dirty clothes
I won't take a shower I won't take a
bath
I don't want to face that so the only
way I get not face it
is smoke cocaine and stay hot
because it numbs me to everything
if you were if you were able to somehow
forgive yourself
for whatever you feel
bad about
and truly forgive yourself not just like
okay forgive myself and I'll drive home
but truly forgive yourself I think I've
taken
a huge step
today just by coming here
I came here
I heard about you
years ago
they made you they said Donald you need
to go talk to this man I said man [__]
that I'm good
something inside me
Donald you need to get honest with your
condition
and maybe in the process you cannot
switch okay
you may receive enough freedom
to make that one decision
that would change the Dynamics of your
life let's go home
and just [__]
and accept your condition
and I'm an addict
I can't take one
so I said
I said I don't know I'm just walking up
the street I've seen the job
and I just asked if I could talk and my
motives was
I just want to get out of this
I went face down
for the first time
in three weeks
and maybe the process you face down
I'll go oh
get that that one
do you understand like I'm the least
religious person you will ever meet but
okay there are some
lessons in
in those teachings that are that are
really useful in situations like this
like
the fact that God Jesus whoever is
does it doesn't
feel like you are any more or less
worthy than anyone else
I've gotten better you forgive yourself
and and there is no one that deserves
happiness more than you and there's no
one that deserves punishment
less than you
I've gotten better right I've gotten
better than him
I can say his name
at least now I can got some acceptance
in that area yeah there's a lot of work
that needs to be done
I don't get infuriated
who you say Jesus
I was the one who walked the prison yard
and was attacked the Christians
and then Believe Me Jesus
I was that guy
today I'm not willing to attack me
I just accept it for what it is because
I I've come to believe after all these
years
if I don't find some power
if I don't find somebody
and whatever entity I choose to go in
if I don't find that and believe in it
I may never have the opportunity to
recover
and that's what I truly believe that
but first of all
I gotta get that first seven days
and not come back
then I have some hope that I can stay so
long term
because it's not a problem for me to
stay so over a year
man
I do it all the time
when I leave here I won't be back
you know but that's not saying I won't
come back
but whenever I come back
damn it's on it's been a month two
months four months and I may not return
I don't know what else to say at this
point
if you could forgive yourself like truly
forgive yourself
and know that whoever you're
religious
thing is whether it's God or Jesus or
whatever
would forgive he wants to forgive you
wants you to forgive yourself then I
think you you might have a little more
peace of mind about this whole thing and
you won't feel like
running down here to smoke
possibly
I don't have an answer to that
oh
all I know right now
is I I need to go ahead and clear my
mind
and once I clear my mind
because I will say there is a God
he'll give me that moment with Clarity
or push the right person in my life in
which I can deal with for you
you know yeah there's a live burden
I care
yeah
nobody God Jesus whoever no one wants
you to self-destruct
and I do it
[Music]
I do that on a regular basis
and you know when I come down here the
skies are always blue
no problem all my bills are paid
I buy a thousands in my pasta
I make that same gambling City I only
want one
I haven't been able to make it out since
to that one
that's the worst hit
the first one
the other ones you just chasing
but the first one opens up the door
and bringing all these feelings and
these uncertainties
that I have no control
it keeps before I take that hit I'm okay
if I can just make it
through that moment
because it's only a month
in that case
but when I take if I take that hit
inside of me it opens up
bring my monster
it puts it unlocks the cage
and my mouse is huge
my words dream
my worst imagination being down here in
the Skid Row
it's running out of crap
and once I get to the Escape
let me run out
anything and everything is possible
for me to maintain
some saying who robbers to check into
other stuffs
to armed robbers
hey it's not bad
and all the willpower in the world isn't
gonna help you there's no such thing as
well
when it comes to crack
no says your dad does not existence
to be quite honest with you I've been
here three four weeks this is the
longest I've been without a hit
in the damn year a month
and what's it been 30 minutes
if I'm not sleeping I'm smoking
and I sleep probably once four hours
every two days
I've been still because of my size
and the way I speak and talk
I have intimidated dope Killers to a
point where they will give it to me just
for I won't get angry
I'm a big guy man you're six six eight
six eight three hundred pounds
you don't want six eight three hundred
pounds to be angry you'll rather having
peace
and now rattle the bushes and Shake
pockets on every one of them
he said I don't have a fear of death
and I don't have a fear of any
repercussion
only thing I have is I got to have it
by any means necessary
yeah
so with that being said
yes I put my life in danger many many
times
yes I'm incapable
of making a decision that's good
earlier early in becoming
when I leave here
I'm going to go get something to eat
I've been eating in two days
I'm gonna call my mom
what happens after that
I don't know I'm putting guys in
like I said this is the longest I've
gone without a hit
in almost a month
wow
all I can say Donald is
keep in mind that you deserve to be
happy
as much as anyone else in the world
I think if you understand and believe
that
and accept that then you might be able
to
do the right thing
next time
okay
I would write this moment
I've been this is the longest members
I'm struggling to stay away yeah you
haven't slept in a long time yeah I'm
struggling
Australia I have a second still a long
time
here's my get some lunch and some coffee
and drive drive up to Pasadena yeah
[Music]
well I go I can't do it don't worry
the pain
is greater than play today
and that may be a good thing
it drove me down the street to become
willing to tell my story
he gave me an opportunity to be sober
for 45 minutes
where I can actually say okay
I got a better chance at making a
decision now
that I have since I've been here
and you know
that maybe that may be the blessing
of me just being willing to come in here
I don't know
but God damn it I got some hope
I got more hope right now than I had
[__] 45 years ago give me a call and
let me know where it is where you are in
a couple days okay
foreign okay yeah
thank you for allowing me to share
Donna thank you very much okay wish you
lots of luck thank you you deserve it
yeah
all right Donald
you're back yeah you know
there's a lot of people cheering for me
no they want me to get home they want me
to go back to my family they want me to
go back to my business they want me to
go back
to around the people I love
and I get to the brink of going
and then I'm engulfed by shame
embarrassment and guilt and that holds
me in one more day
and one day turns into two days you know
my mother's 96 years old
I called and I spoke to her and she said
no matter what you're going through baby
I just want to hug you
and you know
I was convicted by that
because I know I should be there for her
to hug for her to hold
because she loved me unconditionally
but then I think of my brothers and the
people around
that I have to face and deal with
I run
because they're going to convict me
for everything
I do that the time that I've been in in
this hell Hall as I would say
I've been convicting myself
many things
I replay it over and over and over and
over again
and I live in the pain
of yesterday or last week last month or
last year
so when
I come home and I want to go home and I
want to be at peace and I want to try a
different route
I get convicted by them things again
and a lot of times I'm here because I
don't want to face the reality of the
pain
that I inflicted upon myself and other
people
and by me being high 24 7 I don't have
to deal with the guilt and the remorse
nor the shame
but once I go home
I saw I attempt to sober up but I have
to live in that guilt that shame and
embarrassment day in and day out
people on the outside say Donald forgive
yourself
it's easy for you to stand on the
outside and tell someone inside the
picture on what to do
I'm in the picture
I don't know how I forgive myself
I don't know how to let go
you know I don't know how to do that
and I'm paralyzed
kind of thought
of myself inflicted condition that I'm
in
it's not Society it's not the world it's
not my upbringing it's not my
neighborhood there's a lot of people I
hang around
I inflict this on myself
because I make a conscious decision
sober
now I'm gonna come down here and take
one
one drink one hit whatever and I haven't
been able to pull that off in 20 years
and that one turns into two weeks and
then two weeks turns into a month
you know
and every day
it makes it easier not to face
the people that hurt every day I stay
down here
it makes it easier for me not to face
them and it makes me more comfortable
with my environment
can I hate this
but sometimes we need a push
sometimes we need somebody to grab us by
the hand and say come on Donald but come
on Ron
I'm gonna walk you through it
I'm gonna pull you out of this
because me and my me and on my own
accord I can't do it
but I know my brother my sister my
friend anyone drove down the street and
said right now
come on Donald let's go I will get in
the car
and I would leave
I can't do it by myself
I need help and that's all I have to say
on this episode
unless you have a question for me no man
I'm happy that you're working through it
maybe a program maybe a friend come and
take you away maybe something like that
might might help you out
because I would leave
hourly
if anyone within my circle and Family
Circle would just say Donald come on
I would drop everything in me
because that's what I need right now
as long as I don't have that
they're trying to tell me to figure it
out on my home
I'm gonna get out of a box
with the same mind that put me in the
Box
the thing to remember being an addict is
you have an on switch you just don't
have an off switch
yeah absolutely right I can't turn it
off
so once you turn it on
there's no stopping it
I've been making it a little easier
there's a person right here on Crocker
and six he has like a church he's a
pastor I thought he was full of [__]
because um
he's right there in the middle of all of
everything
but he say his mission is to put people
in a safe place who's doing God's will
and he's the first person I have really
been able to open up about
with my feelings about God
and he gives me some type of clarity
because it's a peace it's a peaceful
place among the jungle
and um it stays like that and people
around it respects it for that reason
and um he's able to preach God to
everybody that comes in there
and I want to go see I haven't talked to
him today the only reason I'm in this
domain is because
what I do
I'm not convicted for what I do
I'm not um
shame base okay I get high okay I gotta
come here to get high because I can't
get high at home I can't get high in my
environment my neighborhood I can't get
high in the motels around my house
because my family and everyone knows
everyone
I can't even walk out to go to the store
without being embarrassed so I I come
here to hide
because there's no reason for anyone I
know
or deal with to come through it has any
reason at all to travel through here
only people travel through here people
get out that's it
and they're not judging me
let's hope I don't make another episode
let's hope my next episode I'll be clean
and sober and I'll be able to go ahead
and
that'd be great that'd be great
celebrate it with with other people I
still have hope
yes
I'm grateful for these moments I'm able
to see
be honest and be be able to release some
of the anxiety
intention to run through my mind and
just be honest with my situation be
honest with myself because it's
difficult to be honest out there
you know it's difficult
and you gave me this platform in which
I can speak my truth only if it's for
five or ten minutes it may be enough
you know
that five or ten minutes I'm not
drinking I'm not getting high so I got
God is giving me some form of clarity to
be able to sit here and speak on it but
I still need someone to grab my hand and
say come on down let's go
I still need that
any more questions no I hope you find
that and I hope
things get better for you all right
thank you thank you